all right welcome to another edition of
a beginner breakdown I am your host Mike
Hummer we have a very exciting topic
once again today none other than Harper
Evan Smith
we will be going over his games from the
expert factory going into September
Harper Evan Smith Raiden was 1972 we had
big big goals of clinching the 2000
rating becoming a chess expert putting
on his little business card but at the
end of the month he was down to 1928 and
we witnessed the games that brought them
down back to the gutter okay so Harper
Evan Smith has the black pieces in this
position against Dini
Magoo kheh okay so Danny starts out
efore so let's see what Harper comes up
with c5 this is silly and very good all
right Knight to c3 Knight up f4 as you
know I've been teaching the classes in
our Ferguson and we had this position
today and I was saying you're playing
the grand prix attack and she's like I
don't see a racetrack so that's Alyssa
for you in Ferguson
okay so g6 Knight f3 Bishop fianchettoed
g3 and none other than Danny has walked
in okay this game look familiar
little yeah that's why it looks familiar
and now Harper Evan Smith okay so you
know this Bishop can't really move right
now this bishops already got a nice
diagonal so what does he do he plays
east six so you don't want to open both
doors right so d6 is much better be six
just locks in this bishop so much and
just weakens the dark squares alright
Bishop up d5 but I guess he had a reason
for it he wanted to open D 5 and so Dani
protects with
three night up castles castles Queen to
e1 Rick be eight as we saw last week or
a couple weeks ago you just want to get
your rook off that off that scary
diagonal so there's no way this Bishop
will ever be able to take the rook and
of course preparing eventual b5 all
right so Dan is gonna go for a g4 so now
Harper obviously could be like you know
I got my big b5 plan my big Queen side
attack going but instead he's gonna he's
gonna panic
and react to his opponent okay so
obviously Danny's probably thinking
about playing f5 eventually if not even
the next move
so Harper's like I'm gonna play f5 and
and and switch the whole board and so he
plays about five and so he gets it in
it's like haha I got it so takes takes
and so now the G file is open and both
Kings are on the G file so this game
went from getting kind of you know just
kind of positional to exciting now
because somebody's gonna get a checkmate
and I bet it's the guy that plays on the
Kings side and so now it's Harper
decides I'm playing on the Queen side
all the action isn't so so okay so a3 a5
so so now Danny redirects his knight
from the Queen side where you know
nothing really importance going on to
the Kings side you know good idea
so Harper's afraid he is like I'm out of
here oh maybe you should have maybe
should have traffic go like that but
alright he's he's buried himself in the
corner
all right it's a d4 c3 he's trying to
lock it up lock up all like Harper's
little counterplay here so now the
Knights move and move into the King said
I love it
and now Harper yeah he plays a very
speculative move here okay so his only
his only way to get anything going is by
pushing this pawning and keeping the
pressure up but by playing a four it
stops all the pressure how did you feel
after that move Danny no he was
expecting you're expecting her just to
play play a four but he's got this nice
nice outpost Berta's night hon b3 huh
right this is not the French yeah you
got mixed up yeah Harper easily confused
yeah all right so now so now Danny his
night went from c3 to hh5 excellent
excellent all right so now Harper's
night instead of playing some mad
defense over here it's just gonna gonna
take that nice outpost on b3 okay so
obviously he plays Bishop e3 or a rook
plant some long range of defense
horizontally alright so clean up attacks
the night it's protected but Harper
wants to get more protection on it or
it's a queen to e8 can't over protect
enough so Queen to h3 so now the queen
is on the same Lane as the King so when
that happens obviously pins and all this
great kind of stuffs can happen so you
shouldn't be shocked by like Oh me I
didn't realize I was gonna get pinned or
or lose a piece or something when the
Queen's on the same line as a king all
kinds of dangerous tactics can happen so
you got to be thinking about this so
rook the g8 so we now even two
is king you know one two three it's like
my kings going nowhere so as I was
saying before his King would have been
like I'm not nicer and happier just just
roaming around you know the Queen side
it's that it's it's very scary it's very
scary
all right so night up attacks eight
seven and you know tactics um happen now
so like just an obvious tactic here if
he goes head with his Knight to b3 idea
which eat I mean he doesn't but if he
would you know you can take here if the
computer would let me and then King and
then mate yeah I'm so good I knew it was
made all along made on okay so so okay
so he puts his night to be 3d on hold
some more and he plays Knight to f8 he's
got the other night protecting
protecting this okay so night back and
now Harper plays a really funny move
here well not yet
just wait coil crane to g6 well that's
getting funny okay so so now Danny's
like I think yes sure yes
all right well yeah I mean I really want
to worry about winning a pawn in this
position where you can win like the
whole thing
alright so Queen to g6 and now King f2
so now
Danny's King is free to roam and you
know he might be thinking about putting
a rook on a g1
all right so h6 threatens nothing
because obviously the the pawn is in a
pin it can't capture the night because
the Queen would get the King
all right so Bishop f3 very good
so now does everybody see what the
threat is
besides Danny obviously you win the
Queen with a bishop there all right so
Harper's got to think of something quick
and I'm sure he doesn't
all right so he's like I'll let hack the
knight but it doesn't work it doesn't
work at all because after Bishop here
Harper thinks he's got it all figured
out he's like Danny I just attacked your
knight
what do you think I was gonna do he
spice in their smile and thinking like
he's got it all so he takes the knight
threatening our queen with check so
obviously we just take even the computer
screaming it take and then yeah it's
like it's the only option and Gibbs all
right there really lacks takes d5 and
thunder elbow to some room right up
front right up front right yeah siren
came at the perfect time so he can he
can tell me when he gets gathered up
here okay so so look at the position
sundaram they just played Queen back 287
do you see a way to what
hack and win the Queen here okay great
g6 yeah yeah see Hartford just couldn't
calculate yeah all right well yeah and
that's the game okay so it's a great one
for Harper so his dreams of becoming
expert are being put on hold right now
all right so Harper Evan Smith you know
now he's got to play a Caleb Denby here
okay he is a player rated less than
Harper Evan Smith crazy from he's from
somewhere in Illinois okay so now we
know all about Caleb okay so Caleb has
the black pieces against Harper so let's
see if Harper can can do something here
all right Harper's plan white places
move d4 okay so f3 okay this is not the
fantasy variation of the caro-kann once
again he's getting confused so f3 not
not recommended so black gets castled
and now Harper's like give me a give me
double pawns already so yeah yeah and
Sundaram notes the white phone going to
f3 is bad yeah yep so Bishop takes the
knight with Jack and gives Harper double
pawns and an isolated pawn okay so now a
b6 a knight h3 more common of course is
efore to get a big center but Knight h3
you know the typical Harper move you
know so now black plays the move Knight
to e8 now this looks like a really
strange move but it actually has a
purpose he wants to try to win the pawn
on c4 with a knight
six of them in Chile it has two paths
all right so now now Harper figured out
a floor and so night up fish up the D
three natural place for the bishop along
the diagonal to win this poem fish up to
a six okay so now he's targeting the C
pawn so he's got ideas of Knight to a5
maybe even Knight to d6 when that pun
Harper Evan Smith he actually figures
something out here pawn that you could
attack but instead he decides to play a
four with ideas of bringing the bishop
to a three so now Knight a5 Bishop a
three attacks the rook and now we don't
want to put our Knight here we don't
want to put our knight in a pen
obviously you know that's no fun so he's
gotta fight d6 and so now Harper
remembers that hey two players are
attacking my pawn I'm going to protect
them so he plays Queen to eat - so rook
up to c8 he could just play c5 right
away but he decides he's gonna get us
work behind it and then play C five so
after Harper castles c5 is played so now
they get your move and sundaram d5 so
capture you can't resist getting rid of
his double pawns but now it comes at a
cost
Bishop can take the bishop so so Queen
takes and who can resist attacking the
Queen right so Harper sees it and now
unlike Harper in the last game while you
didn't even get to play Knight to b3
this Knight w3 has a lot more punch okay
tax the rook
Knight up or purse bringing the other
night in real gets on the same line as
the Queen so now we might have some
tactics coming here obviously we can't
do it next move because they could take
so he just protects the pawn some more
Queen up Queen off the the e-file rook
over protects the pawn bishop to a3 so I
guess it's okay because he does get his
move in or why do you think he moved his
bishop from a3 to be four why in the
world would would anybody on earth even
consider that plan what's the follow
what's the only logical move I know I
know it's a it's a twisted idea to do
Bishop to a3 to be forward but why in
the world would you ever even consider
playing that there's only one logical
move for white and now that coincides
with Bishop to b4
how about 85 fine
so it's not the best idea in the world
but yeah that's a bad so so anyway so he
he got it and so there it is so his
bishop is now really in a lot of trouble
well not in trouble but it's not really
doing much it looks more like a big pawn
than anything
so Caleb decides hey you want to trade
your bishop for my knight let's see
let's see he's like yeah of course my
bishop can't even move of course I'll
take it Thank You Caleb okay and now
Harper has a past D pawn okay so things
are looking good for Harper his opponent
just just you know offered the trade
Harper took it and now he's got D pawn
fortunately there's a lot of stuff in
the way but we'll see what he can do so
first things first he moves the a pawn
so I guess the this pawn can never be
protected by his buddy on the 8th a file
so it work attacks the attacks the pawn
rook attacks the pawn rook protects the
pawn pretty basic stuff here Knight up
threatening maybe even to jump to a 5
here so Queen attacks this pawn so Queen
protects the pawn and gets behind the
point and now one two three Oh waste
they're all just three away you know the
work is still protecting but one two
three three alright so so now Caleb's
got to get get his pawns rolling so he
wants to have the big big breakthrough
on on the Queen side here he wants up
passer
so Knight up protects the UH yeah we
could distract the rook with by pushing
but instead he gets both of his men
behind the pawn here so once again
they're both everybody's on the B file
they're all going for this so Queen
comes back and blocks the D pawn and you
see through x-ray protects the the B
pond so Harper can't take the pressure
anymore so he takes it takes it and now
caleb has to pass pawns while Harper
only has one so c3 and there's a very
interesting tactic in this position here
yes for white let's see it to believe it
Knight takes pawn takes rook takes rook
takes
well yeah if you take with the Queen
you're just not gonna be fast enough
obviously there's a lot more things to
calculate you don't have to take with
the with the rook you can take with the
pawn but it's just something uh
something Felicia
it's just something interesting to take
a look at so instead of Knight takes c3
here he just moves the rook okay all
right so Harper moves the rook I mean
what else is he's not gonna sit and
calculate it'll just move the Brook okay
so night night back up Ford okay so now
he's threatening g5 here so Queen pins
the Queen so like Tate
well okay just faster with his plan
knowing that after Queen takes Knight
takes wait what's the question
well Queen to c4 that's a c4 and the
only way you can't even move out of the
line okay because the kings in this line
okay so anyway it goes Czech Knight
takes and he decides to take Harper's
pawn so Knight attacks the rook the pawn
and the poem so rook up rook takes pawn
or cakes and they takes rook attacks the
night so he moves the knight protects
the pawn Knight
I guess the rook nobody really knows
who's winning here I mean they both have
passed pawns but uh black has some
activity here he's got a lot of passed
pawns Knight takes rook yeah well that
would be a good move for white if it was
White's the move that's what he's
threatening right now let's see what he
does here he moves it okay so Harper
Harper didn't want to trade pawn for
pawn so he he advances his past pawn
finally so g5
hopefully the take you do not take here
or else Knight would take your pawn and
you wouldn't like that
so what what moved you have better then
pawn takes pawn here maybe we can just
protect the pawn Oh protect it yeah so
take take rook attacks the pawn Knight
protects the pawn
rook protects the pawn fi and now here
is when Harper gets bluffed they say
there's no bluffing and chest just than
poker but we got a book even by Vladimir
tuck macaw of risk and bluff and chest
the art of taking calculated risk
endorsed by knew and chests okay oh it's
a nice gear he's a coach or second you
know interesting all right so it's a
very good book here all right so so here
comes Harper and he gets Bluff so bad
all right so so Caleb's like wow you
know this ponds not doin anything he's
gonna start running his pawns down my
throat I better do something so he takes
a calculated risk and it's good to know
your opponent it's much easier to bluff
a simpleton then you know a shark right
yeah
yes we all know what Harper is so so so
here comes Caleb Devi he
well first you check okay and then and
then you take the take the pawn with the
night so so now so hard for evan smith
you could take of a free night you're 95
right yeah yeah yeah don't don't
overcomplicate it
so after Knight takes right what move is
Harper so afraid of
work work to be seven well now it
wouldn't be afraid of that
how about Rick to be to meet you okay
okay work detail what's funny is if if
he plays that we have like mate and
fourteen here okay well we're analyzing
this position it's white to move he
cannot take the pawn because he this
rook isn't a pen okay so what
suggestions do we have for white in this
position keep in mind we have mate and
fourteen according to ripka
are Houdini or whoever we have any hope
all right should we just say man man we
should have never taken that pawn we
were right no let's let's be better than
Harper okay let's be better than boy so
pawn d7 does work it's not the best so
after rook takes rook check King III and
Knight blacks and Harper's pretty sad he
can't even his opponent you can't even
play that move yeah I told to it hit
don't do it so that that's good we could
also just play Rick takes pawn takes he
gets a queen well we get a queen yeah
and then we check them again
yeah and then oh man and uh it's going
to be bad to be Caleb here so and then I
mean do we have checkmate yet no but
it's pretty fun it's pretty fun huh
right so this this has what I mean
we got Queen check here you can't go
here how is this complicated where can
he go
yeah but we have checkmate where would
where you go to the side checkmate
all right all right let's go to the
other side you want to go you want to go
to this side how's that that checkmate
and it's gotta bow because it's know we
just lost everything yeah yeah very
smart very smart so so this will sway
they're both great as long as you don't
lose your knight comically just I just
doing that for show but all right so so
let's see so let's see how he gets
bluffed here all right so Knight takes
already decided not to calculate
anything and just say well I just take
rook takes the pawn and
yeah yeah yeah so check King up yeah
absolutely
so I mean Harper I mean he's not doing
too bad in this position right he's got
just as many pawns as the other guy rook
c8 check yeah but yeah Harper stops a
little short yeah let's see if Sundaram
had a better idea that all right Harper
here I'm very excited to see I mean you
got almost yeah I'm with you you got a
check right you gotta check now I'm
seeing if your move is better than
Harper's Oh Harper you know it's cut
it's gaining on Harper you're hella
trouble it's a lot of trouble
all right no Sundaram you win Rick see a
check let they let the record show works
the H disappear here that are Evan Smith
so Rick attacks the pawn
all right d7 here so what do you think
Caleb plays here I bet he plays a work
b8 cannot be the recommended move
because check boo
so we're in dire straits here huh so so
what's the only move black can make to
stop this guy from getting a queen good
rook d5 it's gonna fall for the same
tactics under them Shaq and then King up
Queen well this is the position right
well this is the position if we move the
King up bad news Queen yeah it's not a
check but but he's got a queen so it's
gonna be checkmate as imminent okay so
so obviously PI everybody saw it on the
board anyway Knight takes D seven rook
takes and the rook takes this pawn bad
for black well you got three pawns and
he only has one so we'll get that pawn
off to the races
why Harper Evan Smith then take this a
pawn when he had the chance is beyond me
maybe he's going for some kind of
checkmate here right but he's only got
one potential Queen Harper has three
potential or Harper's opponent Kayla
plain black has three potential Queens
so check so he gets he gets the a pawn
he gets that and check and this is
pretty much just gonna be a draw yeah
it's boring it's boring so they're like
I'm bored you're bored we're not gonna
play 50 moves draw okay so so that's how
the games drew yeah Harper Harper he
didn't bother trying to win
even though weighs up a whole night in
the name game but but that's alright
well that's hard for Evan Smith for you
good luck ever becoming a chess expert
buddy